hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva hello
reject nation I'm John Humphrey I'll
going allamanda Terpening you seem very
comfortable I don't want to mess up the
reject nation I understand I appreciate
that very much mr. chirps Anji Terpening
friend of arson paced around visiting
from Texas who's here with us today
you like patreon yes I do do you like
walking between worlds being a member of
the reject nation but now also being a
reject it's actually pretty fun and
interesting because you see both sides
that's pretty awesome yeah it's really
boring on this side my god it is cool
yeah I was way better
I'm the curtain and it mostly just phone
to keep the sound for Magnus yeah we're
going to check out from one of my
favorite channels today this child also
we don't subscribe to these guys please
do it there what culture 10 more truly
terrible extras who ruin their scene
don't tell me guys you guys are
hilarious Brits we're going to a patient
add a shout out for Kent McKnight Kent
and we'll do it after though after we
check out the video but Kent if you're
watching watch more
Hollywood has something of a problem
with extras these trihard diehard oven
crop up in our lives because
over-the-top actions in autumn accepted
let's check this guy out the james bond
fund sweepa me i wanna hear why let's
get on with another double digit list of
these dispensable jokes with this in my
angel to approach comment is a 10-1 and
colorful extras who ruined their seat
number 10 not quite kicked in the chops
Return of the Jedi
what would the rather quick death of
Boba Fett in the Sarlacc pit bottom
eternity as it's another tragic passing
this extra who despite not even being
touched by Luke's but that still decides
to throw down his blaster and dive
needlessly to his death it's an oversell
to ridiculous degree thrice the man I am
must get on camera
gladiator behold the greatest creep in
the history of movie extra work not
content with being dropped into a
background crowd this man obviously
decided that he had to get his face on
camera no a slight problem with being
sat behind a pillar no problem no he
simply leans into the shot without the
care for the wheelers more immersion of
the scene mercifully stopping just short
of war likely and shall taste random
evasion commit Planet of the Apes in the
original Planet of the Apes Charlton
Heston's George Taylor sums the abuse of
being pelted with stones by the Apes who
seem to take great relish from his
suffering and seem intent on making it
even worse well all but two of them
anyway because two of the extras under
the heavy simian maker obviously weren't
happy with having to be lumbered with
stoning duty that day but you have this
monkey visibly flinching at the baying
mob instead of joining in and then
there's this one who throws a stone with
such a lag of gusto that you suspect
John Entwistle the worst butcher loaders
of the lost art give them the action
going on in the foreground of this
iconic Raiders scene it's very possible
you didn't even see the extra giving
butchers a bad name in the background he
is literally the worst butcher in the
history of butchering and all he's
actually serving is a delicious slice of
limit Ickx storm not bothered made the
day after tomorrow one of the things
that the day after tomorrow does really
well is to sell the terrifying doom of
this mega storm that's so furious that
millions of users would die in seconds
like ants under a foot however one of
the extras cast in the film clearly
didn't get the memo that he was supposed
to be in anyway scared by that notion
even if everyone else is running and
screaming towards sanctuary he simply
stand seeing their bothers gluten-free
though his role is significantly cut
from Jurassic Park you're supposed to
accept the Dodgson is a bad dude right
down to the fact that he apparently
refuses to close car doors this might
have gone completely unnoticed were it
not the extra employees who played his
driver who clearly decided his character
may be put out by Dodgson Meggie can
close the door and channeled his inner
diva to show his disdain offering an
angry flourish that is impossible to
unsee before possibly the best actor a
lights out group the room is obviously
notorious that tommy was those
incredibly unique approach to filmmaking
and acting the acting is stunted the
line delivery unintentionally uproarious
and the script nonsensical it's a work
of art only in the majesty of how much
it gets wrong but in amongst all that
other garbage was a gene so far
unappreciated a lady actor of such
incredible skill that she doesn't even
let the fact that she's been saddled
with not having anyone to talk to a
party scene get her down remarkably she
plows on regardeth and pretty much
becomes by far the best actor Wow
that punch-drunk extra Million Dollar
Baby
there's something very romantic about
boxing it's a brutal than letting plant
whose distill drama lends itself
perfectly to cinema which is precisely
why there are so many good boxing movies
out there and it seems like there's one
extra in Million Dollar Baby who is so
in love with her every single punch like
Swank was laced up and legs
hahahaha so number two never hire a Mon
Calamari opera star the Gemini star wars
have an extras problem going through the
bucking it's had
and now this you keep them dead you it's
probably quite difficult for Mon
Calamari to see properly given how far
apart their eyes are and it's also
probably extremely difficult for the
actors within their rubber suits to see
also this might well explain why this
bridge officer on Admiral Ackbar staff
is so comment be unable to navigate his
way around his own control panel
momentarily losing the button he's
obviously supposed to be pressing and
number one that phantom puncture the
Dark Knight Rises the Dark Knight Rises
had some stunning action sequences and
given Christopher Nolan's notorious eyes
with detail and for creating spectacle
you'd think that he would have only had
the very best bite choreographers and
stuntmen but thanks to the sheer scale
of one of the climactic battles in the
trilogy and Nolan clearly had to ask
actress to fill in for the stuntmen and
some of them seem to have taken measures
to make sure that they didn't actually
get harmed at all like this guy who
knows sure he didn't hurt any of this
followed background artists by simply
punching the air mass is actually a
cameo of Lloyd Ventris all the gentleman
ghost probably not though and that's
only from the other extras who shot for
the moon but ended up in negative space
well let me know about them in the
concepts below and why not swing by what
Coach cons lawn using items like this
every goddamn day as always our be Jules
you've been awesome last week you soon
oh great video man strong attention to
detail these guys have their yeah
there's some of those other like I would
have never noticed that if you go ID
everyone yeah you know no into the
camera I would have never paid attention
to that like makes me wonder how do they
do the research for this topic they just
watch a bunch of movies and just keep
looking in the background are they going
off the top of their head or things that
they actually notice do the thing is now
that I've seen this video I'm going to
be watching the backgrounds of things so
much harder yeah I'm looking for things
out of place with the extras and stuff
like that so this is a long day is
milling around on set you know and
costume having not much it make sense to
me that extras might sometimes do that
because a lot of times extras are people
who actually want to be legit actors and
so they're just trying to get their face
in the shop so they can be like welcome
you know I was a featured extra
in aquila in the beef really it was
right after my famous debut on it so is
Sunny in Philadelphia as kid number two
what does he like 40
dude I feel like I just watched a part
of that episode yeah yeah that just now
is crazy thank you on the beat at the
spelling bee I'm sitting right next to a
keel oh wow have you seen a kid wannabe
I'm nowhere
did you do something crazy did you like
make sure you got your mug in there I'm
pretty sure you do see me a few time you
actually watch a kid on the Beals follow
me I'm right next to akela the entire
time and the bee I got an Archie came
out of me so hard
totally I mean look at you
well she did it the first thing they
pointed out with Return of the Jedi oh
really it's not man though I would have
call it an extra they wouldn't have an
extra just do such a pretty big thing
for an extra to be doing right there to
be kicked off and falling off a platform
is definitely it's done that choice of
which take believe that angle yeah
because it's very obviously guys I'm
being kicked but it is correct me up
though the point is that you see the
thing is the first one is the agents
like flinching and stuff I was like okay
maybe that was just an actual choice but
the second one yeah we're like she's out
of there pair it's hot outside you have
us in this makeup right now everybody in
the foreground is really going at it
I'll be back yeah another they won't
notice me doing this I made my 200 bucks
to the day the wrestling part when I was
pretty good yeah that's that is an extra
trying to get more juicy I actually I
liked that moment because that moment
just make sense you know lately I do
just like walked away from the car with
the door open I would be like hold the
door we know they could have been a real
thing they had have been like a real
directions bill bird gave him to do
yeah like make it work better because he
is just walking away I did enjoy and
still very likely do those things really
let's just shoot in the master so the
audience can see everything that's going
on and you decide what to pay attention
to or I'm just reading it to this way
too much and that was just an extra
trying to shine a little bit oh yeah
I'll bet that gesture those kinda
gesture was weird yeah it seems so
unnatural
is it wick play I get what he meant me I
don't know what this yeah arm stop
working half with very unnatural and a
million dollar baby guy I could kind of
believe that but he is the only one in
the crowd who is he's like way to Jack
up and down yeah it's more than shy get
your face in the shot it's one thing to
really try to stand out and be noticed
yeah well you know it's the boxing that
movie just had a few too many you know
you just like pounding brewskis well I'd
want to imagine like yeah don't break
your neck I feel like you probably came
up with a lot of backstory for that
character yeah yeah created the entire
world
yeah yeah this guy's the only thing that
gives him meaning and he is gonna bring
the agreement after a life of trouble
he's not boxing and just everything is a
Batman when there's actually a second
one they didn't mention which one in
beginning with the Cat Woman and Batman
when they're fighting a guy just falls
over oh I remember that I remember that
another voted on here they didn't say
anything well this video is called 10
more truly terrible eggs oh so I might
they might be when I go to the first one
but in this one too he is punching dead
air yeah sure I feel like winds up doing
it yeah like what are you punching your
Ivan in front of a guy pretending a
bunch of dude beat an extra instead so
boring ever done it no every time we
don't not not not lately but I have in
the past I think it we might have to go
to John I are considering going back to
it when I moved here I was actually
about trying from an extra just trying
to get my foot into the door the leaders
there are people who make a good living
off of it yeah but they also segregate
the crap out of you on some good-looking
someone you know what a confidence and
then to my eyes you will you will your
first set you like the ad is gonna walk
up to you be like taking coming for me
yeah how they I come over here you up
actually wants to be a lead right now
yeah we can't get you somebody or other
on set so uh you want to buddy
memorizing like you just got to read
these off and I mean without you car to
feel you don't worry I can see it
happening with you Andrew yeah I feel
like if I were to tell someone I'm
really good looking I couldn't look him
in the eyes like watch that I'm really
good with me you have that confidence
man alright a girl of confidence
you're really good-looking before this
video is done Kent McKnight ken's
McKnight we don't have a photo of this
guy on patreon it's like man what do I
go off of here other than the fact that
his name's Kent McKnight can we scrap
this guy that is not your real name are
you guy clearly love Superman and Batman
he made a name to kind of disguise it a
little bit
well maybe Kent is like a 1940's Private
Eye maybe or he loves Superman
okay I'm not Superman to any values so
reference to it right here I love them
Dutch pretty better it is it is a cool
name it's cooler than my first email
Wayne Grayson a yahoo.com huh get it do
you get it
Wayne Gretzky and Dick Grayson yeah yeah
I know the meaning of my email mrs. Dunn
of the criminals you don't bus but Ken
McKnight thanks for being a part of our
patreon my friend you do have a really
sexy name and I'm sure you have a sexy
personality if there's one thing I've
learned from Terpening being here is
that all the people on patreon are sexy
it's a requirement it is a required we
don't make you pledge unless you are
actually legally sexy we do the next
Google hangout a lot send you a card
says a sexy move yeah yeah we'd like a
subs are picking us our personal sexy
patreon card and actually when we join
you do get about you know 10 to 15%
sexier you know just as a free
byproducts like money or fruits Amazon
well included in iMovie there and we'll
edit that in a really noticeable editing
believe the part where we talk about it
so wait wait one subscribe to the rail
reject subscribe to what culture click
notification bell death John Humphrey
Twitter and Instagram tips myth on
Instagram patreon is a real website what
do you know bye